et à l'assemblée nationale les députés
ont été très critiques justement ce
matin vis-à-vis de la stratégie
vaccinale mise en place par l'exécutif
réaction du chef de file du groupe l om
à l'assemblée nationale est là président
du rassemblement national christophe
castaner et marine le pen au micro de
david kelly face au matin heureusement
que les vaccins viennent d'autres pays
et il ya une volonté de l'europe de
s'être portée très tôt acquéreurs et de
faire des propositions d'acquisition sur
l'ensemble de l'offre des vaccins
disponibles et aujourd'hui l'europe ne
freine aucune possibilité
il ya aujourd'hui un décalage entre la
capacité vaccinale la capacité de
production mondiale de vaccins et le
besoin mondial et donc nous voyons
comment nous sommes mobilisés l'europe
sera 17 été dit c'est cet été le premier
continent de production de vaccins pour
l'ensemble du monde et évidemment pour
les européennes pour les français
monsieur le drian l'assument
très clairement il assume le fait qu' on
refuse d'aller chercher des vaccins où
ils sont disponibles pour des raisons de
géopolitique sert qu'on met en danger la
santé de nos compatriotes parce que on
ne veut pas du accent russe parce qu'on
ne veut pas du vaccin chinois
moi je pense que quand on est face à une
crise sanitaire aussi grave est aussi
lourde que celle ci il faut ne pas avoir
de considérations géopolitiques
il faut penser à l'intérêt des français
d'abord et par conséquent aller chercher
les vaccins où il